oui bon ça me gêne de parler après
le rapporteur qu'a conclu mais en fait
excusez-moi messieurs je veux pas qu'il
peut me répondre peut-être la sécurité
sociale parce que vous je vous ai pas
entendu répondre à la question les
évasses sont-elles organisées sur tous
les territoires ultramets notamment la
nuit la nuit alors vous avez un peu
compris la situation de la Guyane moi je
parle de la Guyane parce que je connais
bien la problématique
s'il y a une évasion de la nuit on fait
quoi est-ce que le Guyanais voué à
mourir en fait s'il y a pas moyen de le
sauver il reste là il peut pas partir
parce que les vols se font la journée
chez nous en tout cas Air France faire
Caraïbes mais sinon trouve-t-on on peut
faire on fait quoi on fait quoi alors
pire pour les communes de l'intérieur
quand la personne peut être sauvée à
Cayenne mais il y a pas de vol la nuit
on fait quoi on est voué à mourir je
sais que c'est un problème pour vous
enfin comme disait ma collègue Catherine
Concorde c'est encore une problématique
que je vous soumets c'est compliqué je
suis sûr que parmi vous vous n'êtes
jamais venus en Guyane donc vous
connaissez pas la Guyane vous pouvez pas
connaître les réalités donc c'est juste
un plus que je vous apporte si vous
n'avez pas la réponse messieurs je ne
vous en voudrai pas mais je veux vous
sensibiliser parce que nous sommes tous
des Français des humains et on a tous
envie de vivre et quand on voit cette
situation ça nous fait mal au cœur nous
les politiciens parce que on essaie de
défendre mais comme disait Catherine
tout à l'heure il faut être ambitieux et
je suis je suis comme toi Catherine je
suis contente de participer à cette
mission continuité territoriale parce
que ça fait trop longtemps qu'on en
souffre et si aujourd'hui le rapport des
deux rapporteurs peuvent vous éclairer
et puis que vous utilisiez comme base je
serais vraiment très très heureuse en
tout cas ça c'est une problématique que
je voulais vous soumettre mais je
comprendrais si vous n'avez pas la
réponse parce que nous on l'a pas nous
on l'a pas on n'a pas les moyens qu'il
faut et ça fait mal ça fait mal de
savoir que quelqu'un aurait été en
France hexagonale on aurait pu le
transporter dans un hôpital pour le
sauver alors que pour l'aiguillages
c'est pas possible en tout cas les
Guyanais de l'intérieur
alors on vérifiera mais c'est juste des
évacés urgentes sur régulation CMU etc
elles peuvent se tenir la nuit comme le
jour s'il y a l'équipe disponible s'il y
a un besoin
urgent de voilà et un vecteur disponible
il a fait un rien n'empêche que ça se
produise pas donc avec les lignes
commerciales mais avec un moyen dédié et
là il y a énormément de situations
différentes mais alors c'est de
l'intérieur vers la capitale mais après
si la capitale ne peut pas puisque c'est
vrai qu'on travaille sur un centre
hospitalier universitaire régional mais
si la capitale ne peut pas en fait quoi
donc ça veut dire que là encore il faut
qu'on attende la journée parce que qui
qui transportera ce malade en France
hexagonale
juste juste lui quoi voilà